in terms of being like that that's so
iconic the Andy Warhol image which is so
famous over there you are with Andy but
here's the actual painting it's been
reproduced so many times but you still
have an original right mm-hmm so you're
okay I'm okay where is it is it in your
house no it's on the road see I sent it
out on the road I'm it's touring without
touring without it's really it's uh it's
at the Chicago Art Institute right now
there's a very big retrospective of all
of Andy's work which I found a
revelation I mean I had no idea that he
did some of the things that you know
very early on he's very uh genius really
cuz you Arnold you were kind of part of
that world he was a fan of yours yes
some effort Jamie wife who is a famous
painter in America painted me at that
time at wha home studio and then whoa or
was there you know pretty much every day
and then he took Polaroid child instead
of painting me also yeah that's one of
them but there's one kid over there
flexing the muscles and he liked that
one and it was all kinds of weird stuff
that was going on there one day I walked
in then the chimney wires was painting
me and I was holding this pose and next
thing I know is there was this big table
and there was like 1012 naked men coming
in to the room and then they were lying
on top of the table and on top of each
other and then Andy would rearrange it
notice that then he would take a shot
with a certain lighting I would take a
photograph a Polaroid and then he will
come to me and he would say just look at
this this if you cut this off and cut
this off
it looks like landscapes I'm gonna call
it the landscapes and that's exactly the
painting that he did it's just off the
ass is kind of like that
because you couldn't really tell ya
really what it was you know in the
hidden painted that so he was very
creative he was a genius in in in in the
way he went about his art and at that
time it was not as much appreciated but
I think that when he passed away
people realized of what kind of a great
artist he was and now of course his art
is selling for 60 80 million dollars in
auctions
[Laughter]
[Music]
you